oh hi there I'll be with you in just a
minute sorry about that I hope you're
all well Jordan yeah all right good well
first things first I want to make an
announcement um everyone out there in
the interwebs land I recently just
signed a contract with PJTV
now before you all go Steven going all
corporate listen you're still gonna get
your free video on YouTube once a week
or big Hollywood wherever you're
watching this every week all that's
going to happen is a production value is
going to be upped and if you want to you
can head on over to PJ TV and see all
their other content along with exclusive
videos that I'm going to be putting up
there so that's about it now this week
we've been going on North Korea punking
us out and Obama appointing racist lady
judges I've had a lot of topics adjusted
for videos but I decided why not just go
ahead and read some hate mail does that
sound fun yeah good it's good Curb Your
Enthusiasm there Gordon I'll see this
week I got Samia from both Muslims and
atheists um all right let's let's read
this one first okay
Mona mom from Cincinnati writes Steven
you xsplit why you expletive badmouth
Islam go to hell you expletive you
better stop okay see one of the thing
about that is um no I'll see what else
we've got here okay right here um Pete
Smith an atheist from Iowa says I hope
you will research the Church of the
Flying Spaghetti Monster and the
religion of past ofin areas 'im maybe
then you'll be touched by his blessed
noodley appendage Wow you know Pete
nicely done the regurgitation of Dawkins
I appreciate it it's it's good to see
that there's still some independent
thinkers left last but not least this
was a sweet girl like this one this was
in regards to the illegal immigration
video I did a while back a man who calls
himself seedy I happen to see your skit
on immigrants I just want to know if you
would love to sit and speak with me
about your views do you live in my area
I want to offer you the opportunity to
express yourself directly to an educated
large Mexico
answers myself OKC CD the mistake you
made in tipping us off that you were
lying was that there are no large
Mexican man's okay
we all know that one just like a unicorn
or Obama's American birth certificate it
is but a fairy tale do you know any you
know any large Mexicans Jordan can you
Cheryl Bronson
bras I guess but he he's what was he
like five nine I'm he had some Python
thing he was that big he was pretty big
was he big all right and I stand
corrected
um just let you know this is all worth
it all of us hate mail is fun to read
through that's worthwhile when I get
great mail from the people you guys over
big Hollywood or YouTube it really makes
my day believe an email from a mom
saying that she's used my video to help
teach her daughter about something
although to be fair you shouldn't use me
to teach anything to anyone really I
mean Jordan contessa well-known terrible
example but uh yeah yeah
thanks again new video next stirs I just
wanted to keep you guys updated check
back some big things are going to happen
so um thanks again I appreciate it did
you cut it you can't you smell good what
button is jammed the route near the red
light still on button a jam here no you
have to get to it you have to hit that
button and shut it off you have to shut
it off right now okay now we have to
know him to Reno and we have to redo it
now I'll just renew it we'll do it in
one take will do I will do a lot okay
zoo no no no screw it okay we'll do a
lot alright and we'll do a lot friggin
things shucks